well joining me now from telev is
Douglas Murray the associate spectator
the co-founder of the Muslim debate
initiative Abdullah Al andalusi and Dr
iseline abues the Canadian Palestinian
Medical Doctor Who's joined me again in
the studio I'm great to see you thank
you very much indeed for joining me let
me start with you if I may Dr Abes um
when you saw that interview what was
your response to the fact that it's an
NHS doctor working and living in this
country who was saying those things
it's important I am coming you know I
heard it I heard many of your
interviews Jihad the word
Jihad my presence here is
Jihad when I'm coming to meet with you
to advocate for my Palestinian people
and for saving lives of the people is
Jihad and this is the highest level of
jihad the
resistance against someone who is
invading you this is the lowest level of
jihad but Jad when I am traveling when I
am going to any place even someone who
is dying because of far away from his
home is a kind of jihad when we are
fasting when we are working work is a
Jihad and that's the most important we
need to understand it not to take it out
of the context in The Limited
understanding of it when I am invaded
with the disease Co what do I do I have
to resist the co and that's when we Face
cancer disease any cancer with respect
you you would not categorize October the
7th as a resistance it's you know I
condemn the killing of any innocent
human being and for me I was born my
daughters were killed before October 7th
yes I was born as a Palestinian refugee
before October 7 my parents were
refugees before 48 they were born in
Palestine so the history Didn't Start
The World Is Not created October 7th
that's what we need and we are
today it's important but let me let me
let me let me continue let me continue
let me continue please today is the 12th
of December today is the 12th of
December where we have more than 23
Palestinians thousand are killed more
than 45,000 are severely wounded even
the damage in the Gaza STP as Bor the
representative of Foreign Affairs in the
European Union it's far beyond the
damage in Germany for 6 years in two
months more than that so even you know
how that's not true actually why no no
no there there was far he he he said
that who said that borell the
representative of the European Union the
Foreign Affairs if there far more people
died in World War II than have' died no
no the damage the damage the damage the
destruction well there certainly would
have been more damage in Germany in
World War II he he mentioned that
himself you can that won't be factually
accurate but my here's my question
though for you it all comes back to me
I'm I'm very happy to platform anybody
on this show right to the point where
they try and convince me that what
happened on October the 7th was not an
act of Terror and when people refuse to
concede that point I I find it very hard
then to have a civilized discussion it's
why I got so annoyed last night well
well can we so you consider the killing
of my daughters as terrorist well I
think it was appalling and I think you
what you consider it as terrorist I I do
not consider Israel to be a terrorist
organization what the kill of my I think
here's a question we have to ask
ourselves which is um since you have uh
defended um uh Israel's operation in
Gaza as
self-defense you have don't misquote me
don't misquote me I've defended so you
don't say it's part of their
self-defense no let me clarify okay I've
defended Israel's right to defend itself
right in fact they have a duty to its
civilians after hamas's repeated threats
since October the 7th to repeat it to
defend is the not selfdefense is it let
me just clarify my position so you know
right however I have repeatedly question
the proportionality of Israel's response
as indeed their greatest allies of not
the response itself doing but not the
response itself though I think they're
perfectly entitled to go and take out
okay so so so may may I continue my
question then I ask you so since as I
repeat so since you have Justified their
response maybe not how they've carried
it out exactly but you justify their
response to self-defense their right to
defend themselves by the terrorist
committed that atrocity okay and and
presumably you refused to co Israel and
you have refused when you've Haven been
asked to co Israel a terrorist uh
organization government or the idea of a
terrorist organization the difference is
here here we hang on let me finish my
question P I have a question for you I
must clarify you're making some
statements a bit misleading this country
considers Hamas to be a prescribed
terror group they do not consider Israel
to be a terrorist organization and nor
do I so that's the position but I'm not
asking the United States the United
States
consider I'm not asking the British
government I'm asking you peers I don't
think govern isn't here I do not think
they're a terrorist now let me finish my
question if I can ask the question as
well right um for us to discuss so
considering that you have Justified the
operation uh that Israel initiated as
self-defense and that you refuse to call
Israel uh a ter a terrorist organization
or terrorist government despite the fact
that um as many pal almost as many
Palestinians gazin have died under
Israel's Precision bombing than the as
londoners have died during the a whole
year of a blitz under German bombing
which wasn't Precision bombing and yet
you still say that well Israel isn't a
terrorist organization I think the
question we should be asking here is
shouldn't you should you be suspended uh
is it responsible to have a person with
your views speaking to the public when
you clearly refuse to uh condemn that
which needs to be condemned which was
worse than the London BR Blitz that with
Precision weapons and the Germans didn't
even have Precision perfectly reasonable
question yes and you've asked me it on
my show the fact you're here and able to
ask that I think is evidence that I'm
prepared to listen to people who will
look me in the eye and ask me difficult
questions well he didn't to say that but
anyway that's fine but that's fine
you're perfectly entitled to it we
believe in uncens of free speech here
but let me ask you the question then
which I ask he's not answering my
question but you haven't answered it
well I have I said I don't think no
terrorist organization despite the fact
that they they've killed almost as many
as Germans did when they bombed London
under the blitz for one year non
Precision bombs I have given you an
unequivocal answer now let me ask you if
you can give me one yes do you believe
Hamas are a terror organization okay and
I'd like to ask you what what do mean
just answer my question well I need I
need clarification well this country has
prescribed as a terror group do you
think they are are you the British
government no to you okay so I want your
I want a clarification I gave you a
simple straight answer what does it mean
no you tell me I I don't know you're
asking me a question you ask question
you don't think they are a terror group
no I want I want your definition of
would you what is a terror group an act
that commits acts of Terror a group that
commits Terror attacks as they did on
October one that commits terror attack
right fine so Define terror do you want
to answer question or not I do but I
just want clarification no no we all
know what Terror please no no we're
going to go somewhere with this we no
we're going to go somewhere with this
right are you going to answer the
question yes once I get your definition
what's a terror attack the definition is
as is laid down in international law
it's committing an act of Terror which
is which is Terrorism are you asking
questions you don't know the definition
of well why don't you tell me what you
think of I don't know you're asking the
question you have no idea what terrorism
is no I want I want you to answer your
question I say massacring 1200 people on
October the 7th in the way Hamas did is
an act of Terror do you agree so so
killing civilians is an act of Terror no
that's not what I said oh so so then
killing cting a mass on that scale is
Terrorism so so killing civilians is not
an act of Terr you're going to answer
let me bring I want
I want to be we have a third guest no
but I want to I want to I want to say
something you know really you
know United States recognize BL as a
terrorist and it negotiates with blo
this is one thing the second October 7
happened and many things happened after
are we here just stuck there as a
snapshot and to discuss it or we want to
discuss what after and what can be done
way that's the most important I think
they they're all important issues but
right now because of what happened in
the Fallout from last night's show I
specifically want to discuss the
definition of terrorism Hamas and
whether a British H is
hang definition I'm going to bring in
I'm gonna bring in Douglas Mur you're
just sitting patiently here Douglas uh
first of all what was your reaction to
this interview with an NHS doctor last
night on this
show
well let me first of all say that uh
it's necessary to clear quite a lot of
things up because we've heard quite a
lot of hogwash in the last few minutes
firstly uh your guest last night is a
member of an extremist organization
hisbah which is banned in many countries
including in European countries and it's
also banned in many Muslim countries
it's banned in Pakistan it's banned in
Egypt and that's because these Muslim
governments recognize that it is an
extremist group that has a revolutionary
ideology that wants to replace
government in Muslim countries as well
as in as do you know J One European
country is banding um Douglas Murray I'm
not going to let you lie to the audience
like you usually do you're going to
justify everything you say on this show
dougas Murray right please give me one
country it's not b in Germany just said
it's
noty you're not listening you're not
listening you're not listening to the
audience Google it for yourself his PT
German
are they banned an organization is this
is this Mr Al andeli can I just check
cuz I can't see you is that him yeah
okay this is a guy he's of no
significance but he's a guy who I have
seen in studios for years spouting
extreme islamist rhetoric many years ago
he couldn't condemn the killing of the
journalist at Charlie ebdo last year he
wouldn't condemn the attempted murder of
Salon rushy now he can't do this he
fails every single test let me get on to
the question I'm not going to engage I'm
not going to engage in a fun fight with
this with this islamist let me answer
the question that peer's put to me
before you try to interrupt again only
if you don't lie let him answer please
first of all let him answer please right
first of all I'm not going to keep being
talked over by this islamist bloard let
me speak first of all your first guest
treated us the first bit of mouthwash
this evening by claiming that the word J
had can mean absolutely anything
nonsense when a big bearded member of
hisbah says calls for Jihad on the
Streets of London then they are not
calling for an inner personal struggle
with the nature of the Divine they are
calling for violence and anyone who
can't recognize that should be
questioned about their own motives
secondly you we've just been treated to
a a monologue about uh casualty figures
in Gaza where do these figures come from
I'll tell you where they come from they
come from Hamas it's quite remarkable to
me that two months after the October the
7th Massacre the two months after the
October the 7th massacres the Israelis
still don't know the precise number of
people murdered on October the 7th
there's a reason for that because it
takes time to work out Massac at that
scale one of the stri one of the
Striking you know I just don't know if
either of your guests are going to allow
me a word in because you are lying the
numb from the ID which are not
accredited no you will you know
interesting hearing somebody who
presents themselves who presents
themselves as a moderate being a
spokesperson for Hamas so let me
continue they are Hamas figures they are
all provided by the ministries of Hamas
which is Hamas which is a prescribed
terrorist organization if you want to
reel off Hamas figures then be my guest
but you are not able to mislead the
viewers of Pi's show by quoting Hamas
figures at his viewers as if they are I
am not quoting it's the
Euro United Nations the International
Community
organizations think they get the figures
from where do you think they get the
figes from thirdly thirdly I will
continue to speak if it kills you
thirdly World War II it is nonsense that
what has been happening in Gaza has as
you said in this endless list of
fallacies that there has been more
bombing in Gaza more deaths and
destruction in Gaza than during World
War do you know anything about World War
II do you know anything about World War
II alone take one German City take one
German City the destruction was on a
scale totally taking London
taking
number will again I
will
I'm going to come back to you let me ask
one
question specifically about the do it is
very important for your viewers to hear
the following definition the definition
of terrorism is the deliberate targeting
of innocent civilians that is what Hamas
specializes in that is what Hamas did
that's what is happening in in Gaza also
is what Israel is is what Israel is
doing terrorism no for the following
reason and again you can lie about this
if you want but do not expect not to be
challenged about it what the IDF is
doing is the same manner of War as the
British army the American Army and all
other armies in the Civilized World they
target terrorists like Hamas and there
are civilian casualties yes there are
but it is not the aim of the IDF any
more than it is with the British or
American AR armies to Target civilians
and anyone who pretends otherwise is is
lying to the public watching all right
Douglas final question before I go back
to the two in the studio here and it's
specifically about the doctor that was
on last night whether he should be
allowed to continue practicing as a GP
when he identifies Hamas as a resistance
group wouldn't say that it committed an
act of Terror said he didn't even
believe that there had been a massacre
uh and was also quite blatantly
homophobic amongst other things well he
didn't actually um
Doug said if no please please let me ask
Douglas the the Medical Association the
medical
association the medical association is
the one who is assigned to I'm asking
Douglas what his VI is Douglas he's not
a medical doctor asking Douglas opinion
dougas well you don't seem to be much of
an impartial Observer of this I have to
say myself I thought I thought slightly
highly of you before you started ranting
as much as Mr Al Andy this evening um
I'll tell you what I what I thought of
appears I think our country has had
enough of people like your guests last
night it's not just that he's in the NHS
why is he in Britain why do we allow
people in Britain to try to overthrow
the state who praise terrorism members
of extremist or what what has Britain
got from this guy exactly what benefit
have we got from him I mean I wouldn't
want to be an NHS patient going to him I
don't know if any Jews would
particularly want to in Britain I don't
know if very many innocent people would
want want to go to this doctor but my
question is not is not just should he be
able to practice I want to know why our
country of Britain has been such a soft
touch for decades that we have Hamas
leaders terrorist spokes people islamist
sympathizers like your guest Mr aland
deloi and now NHS doctors who are
members of of of groups like hisbah that
stand on the Streets of London call for
Jihad call for Muslim armies to arise I
don't think our country benefits
anything from these people I think
people like that should leave we have no
need of them dougas Murray thank you
very much indeed for joining me I
appreciate it let's come back to you
gentlemen uh to wrap this up let me
start with you uh Dr Abalos look
passions Run High here on both sides I
get that but there have to be certain
points of agreement don't there and one
of the things that I find very hard to
deal with like I said at the start of
this debate is when people simply won't
accept what we all saw with our own eyes
because Hamas put it out on their own
videos through their own social media
platforms what happened October the 7th
was a terror attack can we not agree
that I am coming here as a Palestinian
yes I am not belonging to any faction
and Hamas is not representing the
Palestinian people we have to understand
it it's part of the Palestinian people
it was elected with a free democratic
election in 2006 since that time we
don't have any election we look forward
to have election and we have to respect
the election of the people and the
choice of the people if you in UK
tomorrow to elect any right fanatic
group what do you think the other people
will say to you if they said no we are
they are terrorists or they are not
accepted they are part of the
Palestinian people whether we accept or
not we need to have a new leadership to
have a new election and then it's our
choice to to do it what is happening as
I said it clearly before October 7
October 7 after after October 7 will
never lead to any positive way it only
aggravates Bloodshed more animosity more
pain more suffering and more extremism I
think I think you may be right and this
has been my concern about the in my view
increasingly disproportionate response
by Israel is it may have the opposite
effect to what they want it may actually
lead to more radicalism destroying most
of Gaza seems to be what the mission
statement is now I don't see how that
helps the situation at all but I do
understand why they want to try and
eliminate Hamas and that's the conundrum
well I'd like to clarify firstly um
Islamic law very clearly saids and
there's no difference of opinion on this
for a th300 years or even more that um
it is impermissible in whatever
situation to Target women children
elderly po non-combatants or those not
uh not reservists in an army so U even
the uh the the Hamas Fighters which were
interviewed on on his radio TV it was
the broadcast was interviewed the
interview uh they said the same thing
that it is PR it is prohibited the the
issue of October the 7th is that there's
a lot there's a big question mark
regarding um what exactly happened I
completely accept let me finish what
what do I mean by this I completely
accept that there was um uh Israelis
were killed who were not combatants it
is reprehensible in Islamic law and
likewise it's IR reprehensible that
non-combatants on the Palestinian side
are killed like for example um an
8-year-old Muhammad and and others in
West Bank who was shot by an R Soldier
but my point is this right and here's
here's the issue which is Michael Clark
who advises might seen on Sky News
talking about Ukraine war he's a
military adviser on channel and also
Channel 4 he describe he said that um
Hamas the the operation they actually
lost control of the operation and it
turned into a spontaneous terror attack
I'm quoting him theba I don't believe a
word of that well well this is what he
says as an my opinion I know well I'm
I'm giving you an expert opinion
cleated and then they gleefully posted
in they didn't in where where did Hamas
do you know that quotation you see no
Hamas people that day gloating about it
are you watching the videos yes I did
did you watch that Hamas spokesman you
quoted that Hamas spokesman on TV did
you see what he said about the attack he
said that they had there was no order to
to Target civilians what what many they
did a general a general consensus of
analyst have shown that there was
looters that came out of who were not
part of H simp my simp
question my simple question is this was
it a terror attack anyone who killed
civilians yeah should be condemned
Terror reprehensible anyone who kills
civilian is a criminal was it a terror
attack what October the 7th and we I
asked you you said what define the
terror attack is that you target C
defition from yes okay you target
civilians right so then I I want to ask
I answer that question I want to ask
that question but I just just for sake
of consistency when the British army
targeted German civilians in World War
II was that a terror attack no because
they were responding to Nazi Germany's
attempt to destroy the world so you're
saying saying so you're saying that uh
because of who they were fighting it's
not a terror attack to kill to Target
civilians are you is that is that what
you're saying we have to wrap this up
I'm asking is that CU I only want
consistency I'm saying there's no moral
equivalence between us defending
ourselves against Nazi Germany who
committed a holocaust that killed in
fact they killed 12 million people did
Britain la war on Germany because of the
Jews huh did Britain declare war on
Germany because for the sake of Jews
Britain declared war did Winston
Churchill in his ultim him to Hitler did
he say stop persecuting Jews do you know
why because at that time anti-Semitism
was so rif that people didn't care about
the plight of the Jew it was only
afterwards after they discovered the
death camps and so on so forth don't
pretend that the Allies launched this
war for the sake of of Jews
anti-Semitism anti-Semitism discover the
of the concentration camps towards the
end of the war
to we did to save our democracy and
freedom and the guess the idea's any the
Palestinians are doing what are the pal
doing the idea with any moral
equivalence is ridiculous but let me
come back one more time before we finish
to my simple question was what happened
on October the 7th a terror attack I'm
I'm and I'm telling you that if you
refuse to call the the bombing the
bombing of burm as a terror attack then
why to leave it there is that not
hypocritical I'm totally to call
if you're willing to call a
terror let's join each other in both
things including the ID as what they're
doing ter not believe ID that's being
hypocritical that's being hypocritical
your I'm happy to cond all this is a
terror attack you have to be
consistent inist yeah pleas you know
yesterday I was listening to the chief
of mad and the chief of shet and he said
it's because of the failure of
diplomatic and and political issues this
is important and there was negligence
and what can we do now and that's the
most important as a medical doctor we
need to stop the Bloodshed to go to
Serious negotiations to use it what
happened October 7 as an opportunity to
bridge the gap between Palestinians and
Israelis and not to repeat it again and
again I'm going to end it there don't
think fire people from their jobs
because they have difference of opinion
in England I don't think British GPS
should be coming on National Television
in this country and breaking the law by
publicly supporting and endorsing a
terror group by the way break the LA a
criminal offense to support a terror
group in this country yeah of course he
did that last night by what when did he
by saying they were resistance not a
terror group he was talking about
justify he was talking about
Palestinians in general is a criminal
talking about palestin talking about
Hamas ham talking he was talking about
watch the interview go back and watch
for the police to inv
palan he broke
Palestinians equal rights throughout
whole of pal you ask me why that's
why again thanks to Douglas Murray to Dr
AB it's good to see you again thank you
very much Abdullah Al Andi thank you
very much for coming in I appreciate
that